[Música]
unos 9000 cuerpos de civiles podrían
estar enterrados en fosas comunes a las
afueras de mariupol así lo denunció la
alcaldía más temprano rusia anunció que
se hizo con el control total de esa
ciudad portuaria esto pese a que las
autoridades locales y el presidente
volodymyr selenski aseguraron que las
tropas ucranianas aún resisten
el expresidente hondureño juan orlando
hernández fue extraditado a eeuu donde
enfrentará cargos por narcotráfico y
otros delitos relacionados con armas de
fuego la justicia estadounidense dijo
que hernández recibió millones de
dólares de cárteles de la droga el ex
mandatario reiteró que es inocente que
el proceso es un curso
la cámara de representantes de florida
aprobó eliminar la denominación del
distrito especial que permite a disney
gobernar su parque temático en orlando y
gozar de privilegios tributarios la
medida se produce luego de que la
empresa criticara abiertamente la ley
conocida como no digas game sólo falta
la firma del gobernador del estado
en france 24 estamos de vuelta con las
noticias que marcan las jornadas fue
valentina torre sánchez y es un gusto
acompañarlos iniciamos este informativo
en la ciudad ucraniana de mariupol donde
la alcaldía reveló que al menos 9.000
cuerpos de civiles podrían estar
enterrados en fosas comunes a las
afueras de esa urbe la alarmante cifra
se conoce el mismo día en que rusia
aseguró que tomó el control total de la
ciudad portuaria no obstante las
autoridades locales y el presidente
volodymyr selenski informaron que aún
hay tropas ucranianas resistiendo en
terreno dennis herrera tiene los
detalles tras casi dos meses de asedio
el ministro de defensa del kremlin
anunció el control total de la ciudad
portuaria de mariupol
y las fuerzas armadas de la federación
rusa y las milicias de las repúblicas
populares de donges han liberado
mariupol los remanentes de las
formaciones nacionalistas se han
refugiado en la zona industrial de la
planta de azov tal el funcionario
propuso un operativo para tomar la
acería pero vladimir putin ordenó en
cambio para los ataques y bloquear las
instalaciones para que nadie salga ni
entre
consideró que el asalto propuesto a la
zona industrial es innecesaria y ordenó
cancelarlo este es un caso que debemos
evaluar quiero decir nosotros siempre
debemos evaluar pero en este caso aún
más sobre preservar las vidas y la salud
de nuestros soldados y oficiales
la toma de mariupol fue negada por las
autoridades ucranianas
mariupol fue es y sigue siendo ucrania
hoy porque hoy nuestros valientes
guerreros nuestros héroes están
defendiendo nuestra ciudad tanto como es
posible se cree que cerca de 2.000
soldados ucranianos muchos heridos aún
se refugian juntos cientos de civiles en
asos tal que cubre 11 kilómetros
cuadrados con enormes edificios búnkeres
subterráneos y túneles o que ya pide
urgentemente un corredor humanitario el
presidente volodomir selenski señaló de
nuevo la grave situación de quienes
siguen atrapados en la situación como
saben no ha cambiado nada
y desde la casa blanca- cuestionaron la
calle del puerto en el mar de software
bueno antes que nada es cuestionable que
putin controla mariupol hay una cosa que
sabemos con certeza sobre mariupol
debería permitir corredores humanitarios
para que las personas en esa acería y en
otros lugares que están enterrados bajo
los escombros puedan salir eso es lo que
haría cualquier jefe de estado en tal
circunstancia y además todavía no hay
evidencia de que mariupol haya caído por
completo os complicó
el presidente estadounidense anunció un
nuevo paquete de 800 millones de dólares
para armamento y asistencia ucrania así
como la prohibición de la llegada de
barcos rusos a los puertos del país
norteamericano
y el kremlin anunció una nueva ronda de
sanciones individuales contra cerca de
30 funcionarios empresarios y
periodistas estadounidenses entre los
afectados están la vicepresidenta kamala
harris y el fundador de facebook mark
zuckerberg quienes no podrán entrar al
territorio ruso por crear lo que moscú
llama una agenda rusófobo por otra parte
la organización de estados americanos
aprobó suspender a rusia como observador
permanente con 25 votos a favor y 8
abstenciones
entre ellas la de honduras argentina
méxico y brasil
en otras noticias el expresidente de
honduras juan orlando hernández fue
extraditado este 21 de abril a estados
unidos donde es requerido bajo cargos de
narcotráfico y otras dos acusaciones
relacionadas con armas de fuego pero
como fue que el mandatario resultó
involucrado en estos casos que afectaron
la parte final de su gobierno lo vemos a
continuación en el informe de luís
mentes el escrutinio presidencial la
silla presidencial al banquillo de los
acusados un giro de 180 grados para el
ex presidente hondureño juan orlando
hernández 10 después de haber dejado el
cargo que asumió desde enero de 2014
que la verdad
improbables
soy docente
instruyendo
hernández podría decirse fue víctima de
su propia ley ya que la extradición a
eeuu fue promovida por el propio
hernández en 2012 cuando era jefe del
congreso dos años después carlos arnoldo
lobo quien se declaró culpable de
narcotráfico sería el primero en dueño
extraditado a eeuu
afuera sus dos mandatos presidenciales
además de actos de corrupción estuvieron
salpicados por un supuesto acercamiento
a cárteles de la droga en noviembre de
2018 las denuncias toman mayor
notoriedad tras la captura de su hermano
juan antonio hernández quien luego sería
condenado a cadena perpetua por cuatro
cargos entre ellos el de tráfico de
drogas en eeuu tras la captura de juan
antonio y durante su proceso judicial
surgieron denuncias que relacionarían al
entonces presidente con el narcotráfico
que es falso que he recibido o aceptado
dinero de estos delincuentes en febrero
de 2000 22 días después de haber dejado
el poder eeuu solicitó su extradición
que fue conseguida por un juez hondureño
a pedido de la corte del distrito sur de
nueva york para las autoridades del país
la extradición del ex presidente es sólo
el primer paso hoy no hace un nuevo un
nuevo escenario
privilegiando pues un estado de derecho
privilegiando el nacimiento e innovación
de sus instituciones vienen más
extradiciones señor ministro si eso es
una una gama que es permanente las
trabajamos muy detenidamente
hernández se convierte así en el cuarto
dirigente de la región tras manuel
antonio noriega de panamá el
guatemalteco alfonso portillo y el
hondureño rafael callejas quien será
extraditado a eeuu
y vamos a florida porque a petición del
gobernador ron de santes la cámara
estatal dio luz verde a un proyecto de
ley que elimina el distrito especial
autónomo de vuelta disneyworld que
permitía cierto grado de autogobierno y
beneficios tributarios en sus parques
temáticos en el área de orlando esto
luego de que la empresa criticar a la
ley conocida como no digas gay que
limita a hablar en las aulas sobre
orientación y diversidad sexual
previamente conversamos con julio
sevilla profesor de negocios de la
escuela de negocios stern y de la
universidad de georgia quien nos contó
qué tanto afecta a esta medida a disney
y a los floridanos
yo creo que puede tener cierto impacto
en disney desde el punto de vista de que
ellos pierden el control desde esa zona
estamos hablando que la la zona que
comprende el parque son más de 100
kilómetros cuadrados y está entre los
diferentes distritos de la florida y
entonces ellos desde la creación de
disney abre en 1971 ellos tienen este
estatus desde 1967 antes de abrirse el
parque han tenido control de cómo se
desarrolla necesitan permisos de la
ciudad tiene su propio cuerpo de bombero
su propio batallón de medicina manejan
hasta cierto punto la policía incluso
generan parte de su energía entonces va
a venir a perder ese control ahora
quiero hacer énfasis en de que esto ha
sido hecho de manera improvisada no se
saben todos los detalles probablemente
disney va a responder una demanda la
legislatura de florida junto con el
gobernador tiene tal vez que refinar lo
que se hizo pero hay un riesgo que sea
del que se ha venido hablando de gente
que disney tiene bonos que han emitido
como una municipalidad normal por el
orden de los mil millones de dólares
para hacer ciertos desarrollos y se dice
de que de la manera que esto se ha hecho
ahora podrían ser los ciudadanos de la
florida lo que tiene que pagar esos
impuestos que eran esos bonos que eran
responsabilidad de disney el líder de
corea del norte kim jong-un y el
presidente de corea del sur muniaín
intercambiaron cartas en un particular
gesto de acercamiento entre las dos
naciones quien respondió a la misiva que
me envió miércoles y agradeció por
tratar de mejorar las relaciones esto en
medio de las pruebas de armas de
pyongyang que han elevado la atención
luego de que corea del norte lanzará
misiles balísticos intercontinentales el
mes pasado
finalizamos en río de janeiro donde todo
está listo para que entre la noche del
viernes y la madrugada del domingo
vuelvan a retumbar los tambores de las
escuelas de samba en medio del carnaval
de río 12 escuelas cada una con unos
4000 músicos y bailarines atravesarán
los 700 metros del sambódromo para
mostrar sus carrozas alegóricas se trata
del primer carnaval tras dos años de
suspensión por la pandemia de kobe 19
que deja más de 660.000 muertos en la
nación suramericana con estas imágenes
nos despedimos continúan con nosotros
que volvemos en breve con más noticias
[Música]